some really good spot bears coming from
all direction we can pretty much predict
where they're going to hunt I'm going to
set up a camera and try and get a shot
of a bear smashing into a salmon I'm
with my camera with my tripod and a bear
comes out of the forest
and the bear lunges down grabs the
salmon picks it up and walks off with it
we haven't got the pillar shot yet I've
come back down with the video kit we're
going to be sitting in the same place as
we were yesterday I set one right in
front of where the last fish was caught
and I also put a camera on a stick
coming out of where the bear will stab
and that will give me a bird's-eye view
so we can see what it's looking at I
think it's time to let them do their
thing
please walk in front of my camera I
think if we just sit it out
we'll get this because it is a very very
cool angle and sure enough about an hour
and a half two hours later Sheen comes
back down I start the camera recording
again and she walks out onto the same
log that sits there and stares at the
water
she just needs them one more meet there
and then she's right in front of the
camera and all of a sudden BAM she slams
a salmon as it breaks the surface of the
water and she grabs it pulls it straight
up out the water right in front of the
lens right in front of the camera one of
the cool things when you nail a shot is
that not only have you just seen
something incredible but you've also
captured it and that is why it's all
about patience
we're just about to go to sleep and that
said do you hear that bear so we decided
to cut out the tent to find out that the
tree two feet from the front door ten
had two bear cubs puppet